it was really interesting to get to the
bottom of the bridesmaid
drama story because what we had heard
time and time again that megan had made
kate
cry but we didn't have any other details
the future queen of england was in tears
over what megan has said to her so let's
talk about this for a second
yes let's finding freedom author omid
scobee set out to debunk this rumor
dating back to meghan markle's 2018
wedding to prince harry actually
speaking to people who were in the room
during the infamous bridesmaid dress
fitting
yeah it was good news all around i think
so scoby tells et's michelle turner that
according to his research
the rumors are false everyone i spoke to
said there were no tears
sure it was stressful there were kids
running around and that's always a lot
especially it was a
hot day the wedding was very soon and of
course kate had only recently given
birth
but there was nothing more to it than
that and let's be honest
we can't think of a time where we've
seen megan or kate middleton
be unprofessional one of the sources i
spoke to was there said to me could you
imagine
a moment in which kate would ever be
unprofessional enough
or let her guard down to cry in a public
group setting and could you ever imagine
megan being so
unprofessional to chastise someone and
make someone cry
in front of a room of others and of
course the answer to both of those are
no
so i hope that we can finally put tales
like this to rest and
you know there's a saying on the royal
beat that it's not old until it's told
so hopefully we've finally reached that
point
[Applause]
and remember the rumor about harry
telling palace staff
quote what megan wants megan get well
scoby's setting the record straight
on that one too how many times have we
heard the tiara
story surrounding meghan supposedly she
had rejected what the queen
had offered her and then harry had
marched into her dresser's office and
said what megan wants megan gets
and really that's what stuck for such a
long time and and what we found here was
actually it was a beautiful moment
whether queen had
really taken her time out to present
five tiaras to megan and that harry was
there
and they picked one and they stuck to it
where it fell apart was afterwards that
megan had actually arranged for her
hairstylist to try the tiara on her of
course we know there's a lot of
technicalities that go into wearing a
tiara for an entire day
and it was important for her to try it
on what they found was that time and
time again that appointment just
wouldn't happen
and as many requests that came in from
her office and even from prince harry
himself
to angela kelly the queen's dresser the
access to the tiara
never happened and it really wasn't
until very close towards wedding that
harry had to contact his grandmother
and say that he felt that angela kelly
was standing in the way that she was
trying to cause problems for megan
and of course lo and behold she gets to
try the tiara on
but of course what followed then was a
completely different story and
it makes you question what the agenda or
the motives are of some of those people
that would have been giving that
information
to the papers in the first place